[Music]
tonight's talk is an interesting one for
me especially because you know as the
more we've been talking about long-term
thinking one of the main questions that
we always get is you know what do you
mean 10,000 years there's not going to
be people in 10,000 years and you
actually start asking people what they
mean by the local climate change really
well climate change mean there's no
people and so and if you look at
evidence you know the Steven Pinker
sense of all all the past is actually
way harder than then the future is and
the president is always better than the
past on and if you look at it on the big
curves through history yet it's never
our it's never our intuition that the
future is better than the past we always
think of the good old days is the good
old days so I'm very interested to hear
what andrew has to say about hope thank
you thank you very much thanks for the
invitation and to all of you for coming
thanks to Stuart brand for will being
willing to have a conversation later I
feel like you're going to know better
than I do almost everything we talk
about here so it's good to keep it
relatively short and then we'll have a
conversation and then we'll open it up
for questions so Who am I I'm as was
mentioned I'm a philosophy professor I'm
visiting at the Center for Advanced
Study I'm also working on this book on
hope mostly related to Immanuel Kant and
some of his followers the reason I'm
interested in the topics we're looking
at tonight is in a way because these
Enlightenment figures were themselves
the first people to really get
interested in them so how should we
think not so much about eternal life and
the eschaton but
about future and the product and sort of
the progress of the species and the
philosophy of history in general where
technology plays a role also interested
in the fact that the Enlightenment
figures were in a way the ones to open
what you might call the moral we the
circle of the moral we or us the people
the things that we count as having moral
status it's not just me it's not my
family my tribe there are reasons to
think that we should go out to nation
state or maybe even all rational beings
enlightenment philosophers didn't
succeed in going all the way to members
of the species they were mostly sexist
and racist but they gave us the seeds
for doing that and we are in a way
indebted to the Enlightenment
philosopher so I'll talk a little bit
more about the moral we in a second and
this book is in a way related insofar as
we asked so it's an edited volume where
I wrote a piece and introduction we
asked younger philosophers to think a
little bit about food and inevitably a
lot of them started thinking about
expanding the moral we to non-human
beings and so the debate about animals
but there's also stuff about artificial
ingredients and there's a really great
long now kind of piece in here maybe the
one that's had the most discussion there
was a New York Times summary of it and
then about 900 comments it's a guy
arguing that in 100 or 200 years when we
have the capacity if we have the
capacity we should we should morally
phase out the carnivores so not just
stop eating meat ourselves but phase out
all carnivore ISM even in the animal
kingdom I don't know what would happen
to the trophic cascade at that point but
it's sort of this if question if we
could do it should we do and he argues
yes and then I'm also participating in a
grant project where we're looking at
hope and despair and optimism and
pessimism and funding projects ranging
from neuroscience to philosophy to
religious studies to playwriting and
filmmaking so in the middle of all of
that right now here's what I'm going to
do tonight give you some boilerplate
about the Anthropy
which may be familiar to many of people
in this audience then I'm going to talk
about the concept of hope
optimism and at the place where they
start to come apart what they mean in
the contemporary context I'll sketch an
account of rational hope and then I'll
give you what Kant would call a moral
argument you'll see what that is for a
kind of Hope even if you're pessimistic
in the context of the Anthropocene I'm
obviously not a climate scientist or a
geologist or a geoscientist so I'm not
going to tell you how we will make it
through the improv scene in its various
challenges but I'm going to talk about
the role a certain kind of Hope might
play in doing that so here's the boiler
plate Holocene is the recent era and
it's recent in the long now sense of
about 12,000 years ago started then and
isn't officially over so the relevant
scientific groups have not approved the
thought that is being suggested now by a
number of different geologists that we
replace it with the kind of step change
to the Anthropocene or Anthropocene the
period in which humanity anthroposophy
comes as impactful as a geological force
in the stratosphere in the atmosphere in
the hydrosphere the biosphere even down
to the lithosphere there's evidence of
us and we'll be in the planet forever
and so people debate a little bit about
when to start dating it but 1945 seems
like a natural point when we started
with nuclear and the various effects
that that has had so we'll see they're
actually meeting one of the relevant
scientific associations is meeting this
year to consider whether to formally
adopt the idea of the Anthropocene in
popular parlance it became kind of
prominent with this article by Oliver
Morton in 2011 and The Economist there's
now 200 newspaper and journal articles
with that in the title just in 2015 I
don't need to say too much about the
nature of the crisis I think we all know
that
a big picture we're in the midst of the
sixth great extinction about a hundred
thousand species per year at least some
of that is our doing there's a general
consensus coming out of the 2009
Copenhagen meeting that we need to keep
any rate rise in temperature below what
they call the guardrail of 2 degrees
Celsius so the 2 degree guardrail
without doing that we face potentially
catastrophic feedback loops and all
sorts of nonlinear progressions and to
runaway warming which would lead to
nobody really knows exactly there are
attempts to model four degrees and eight
degrees but there's an admission that
it's not really clear what to think
about that it's certainly not
controversial that even with the two
degrees which is going to produce twenty
feet of sea rise we'll have some big
changes it'll affect of course the
global poor the most the people in
Bangladesh and Vietnam and so forth more
locally it will also affect Silicon
Valley so it looks like a lot of great
infrastructure and resources I think
Intel survived and NASA but that's just
that's just 55 inches the the red there
so 55 inches around five feet a little
less than five feet and Silicon Valley's
its market will be happy that Stanford
looks ok here's 25 feet so we won't be
standing here anymore
yeah that's right it real estate prices
go even higher presumably and then the
IPCC makes it clear that even if we stop
relatively soon we end up still with a
lot of progression in terms of effects
even into a long now several millennia
of see rise temperature ice melting and
so forth here are some of the numbers
we've already burned 2100 gigatonnes
2100 billion tons since the Industrial
Revolution this is just co2 so
side the other greenhouse gases to stay
under the two-degree guardrail if we
want a 50/50 chance
kind of coin flip chance then we should
only burn another 1600 billion tons if
we want a 75% chance than only 700
billion tons what we have in proven
fossil fuel reserves is something like
2,800 billion tons and you know people
try to put a money value on that I don't
even know how to think about 15 trillion
dollars but the thought is there are
these assets that are stranded there
it's going to be very hard to convince
people who have access to them and
rights on them not to bring them up so
that's our situation if we don't
convince them not to bring it up then we
end up with something like this
potentially those business now yeah now
maybe that real estate prices go down
because it's an San Francisco
archipelago that's a kind of business as
usual picture other people suggest a
kind of business as usual plus
innovation so Rex Tillerson the CEO of
Exxon recently said famously that
climate change is just an engineering
problem you might remember Jeb Bush in
the in the primaries at some points that
climate change will be fine at some
point two guys in a garage will figure
out what we need to do and we'll fix it
so they kind of you know we will be able
through innovation to fix it there might
be something right about that but it's a
little bit sort of naive sounding then
there's the revolution on the other side
of the picture according to which we
have to rapidly decelerate and stop
using all the carbon that we're using
and also for justice purposes let the
poorer nations the developing nations
use the rest of it that's 700 billion
tons that we could still use so we have
to shift carbon credits over there and
radically change our ways and then
there's a couple of different efforts to
talk about what you might call the good
Anthropocene or the soft-landing
Anthropocene people who think that yeah
we need to reduce and so forth but there
might also be some innovations that we
could introduce the terms of
geoengineering Oliver Morton the guy who
wrote the
a piece and the economists just came out
with a book on geoengineering Stuart in
the talk at the interval last January
with Paul Sappho mentioned something
about this idea that we could spray
sulfates up into that atmosphere and
that this might help prevent some of the
effects of the greenhouse gases at least
for a little while some people worried
that this is playing God I noticed that
you in the last version of the Whole
Earth Catalog say we are as gods at this
point and mean we might as well get good
at it so it's kind of you know owning up
to the situation so let's just call it
so those are the different ways in a
kind of middle way picture let's just
call the outcome that we want however we
get there carbon justice let's just call
it carbon justice
well think of that as staying below the
guardrail and also giving the people who
haven't had much carbon burn a chance to
burn as much as we have okay so that's
our goal carbon justice let's say you
know one thing you might ask is what
would motivate us to take that on as a
goal after all we're talking about not
just people who are spatially extended
far away from us the global poor the
southern hemisphere for the most part
but also temporally
far away from us so I talked about
expanding the moral we why do we expand
the moral we the us that we care about
the people who have standing in to
non-existent people future generations
philosophers like these kind of puzzles
they don't exist they don't have rights
we don't owe them anything so why are we
so worried about it maybe we should just
go with business as usual but that feels
wrong somehow we don't tend to think
that we have to make decisions in an
effort to produce as many
well-functioning future people as
possible we don't think of condoms as
weapons of mass destruction we don't
think that preventing people from
existing is a bad thing so why do we
worry or feel we have obligations in
some way to future people so there are
some puzzles there that philosophers get
into suppose we do though think that we
have some sort of obligation to keep
things going
think it's like an intrinsic good that
there be human beings on the earth then
we'll have to try to see how we can get
to carbon justice the other problem here
is it's a massive collection collective
action issue so not only do we have to
worry about what other nations are going
to decide and the Paris treaty did get
some distance in that regard but we have
to also worry about kind of defectors in
our own communities you know what if I
try really hard and cut way back and
then my neighbor does it looks like he's
not going to in a lot of these games
theoretic contexts when we're talking
about prisoners dilemmas and so forth
you're in a state of ignorance in this
case we're not even in a state of
ignorance it looks clear that a lot of
people are gonna defect it looks like
some nations that feel they are owed
certain carbon credits may not toe the
line so I think that there's a you know
there here's the carbon justice we feel
like we want it for some reason we're
obliged morally to go for it but there's
a threat of demoralization I think we
all feel this my students certainly feel
this and I mean that in two ways sort of
double entendre demoralize
psychologically going after this just
starts to seem like something that's too
hard it's enervating especially when i
don't know if anybody else is gonna
really do what I'm trying to do and then
you so you lose your moral the sort of
moral driving force behind your activity
you start to become apathetic or maybe
opportunistic in certain ways you eat
drink and be merry because we're not
going to be able to fix this so that's a
sort of bad thing from a moral point of
view and yet it seems to be something
that we all face and in spades when you
think about something like the
Anthropocene so it would be great if we
could just convince ourselves sort of
leap of faith style that you know when
we act everyone else will act and
somehow we'll get there and carbon
justice will be achieved but that just
looks irrational it looks like bad faith
mean maybe there's a pragmatic reason
for going in that direction in some
cases but this looks like it'd be hard
to do and also a little bit
you're rational and so what I want to do
is develop a conception of hope that
might play a certain sort of
motivational role that allows us to keep
going even in the face of these issues
regarding the Anthropocene and the
collective-action problem but doesn't
require a kind of irrationality so let
me give you a brief brief history of
this concept Elpis is the jerk the
German the Greek term that is often
translated as either expectation or hope
what's interesting there is that
conflation in the crack Classical period
expectation and hope are not clearly
distinguished expectations something
like what we call optimism you expect
something to happen there's also an
ambivalence in the Classical period so
as Pandora's jar suggests Zeus gives
Pandora the jar she opens it she's the
kind of Greek version of the biblical
Eve she opens it all these curses come
out and are visited upon humanity she
looks inside and there's one thing left
and it's hope and Hesiod doesn't tell us
whether that's the thing that consoles
us when we have to face all of these
other curses or whether it's another
curse of its own and different people go
different directions in the Classical
period you're Rippa tease and Plato seem
to think of hope as something to be
avoided Nietzsche sums up their view as
this Zeus did not want man to commit
suicide no matter how much the other
evils might torment him but rather to go
on letting himself be tormented to that
end
Zeus gives us hope a very pleasant
thought
so the ambivalence continues throughout
the ancient period Aristotle says hope
is just a waking person's dream the
Stoics think that too that hope is just
the opposite side of fear and that you
only cease to fear if you cease to hope
so just counts work on your own moral
character and don't worry about things
outside yourself in the Christian period
you get hope becoming a kind of virtue
that's directed towards the afterlife
and so it's a holy good thing in the
modern period here's Hobbes here's
Descartes they think it's a gears lock
they think it's a good thing but they
also come
in the classical way with expectation or
optimism they think of it as something
that we should expect and part of that I
think is that probability theory was not
really developed in till 16th 17th
century so a lot of these people aren't
necessarily making a big distinction
between the possible and the probable
and the way that I want to in a minute
probable actually meant in the medieval
period if you said something was
probable what you meant was something
like a lot of the authorities have said
this a very different notion of the
probable than we have and then Spinoza
who actually goes back to the stoic
position it says eradicate hope oxford
english dictionary really pisses me off
because it makes the conflation and it's
still there it's still up there to hope
is the expectation of something desire
desire combined with expectation
confidence I think that's wrong so let's
start with optimism I just want to sort
of get your intuitions going about what
a sort of common sense notion of
optimism might be optimism that
something is going to occur looks to me
anyway likes something like this it's a
desire that the thing occur you desire
nice weather tomorrow and you think it's
probable you think the odds are better
than 5050 that it's going to rain that
it's going to be sunny tomorrow so
that's something you want and it's
something you think is probable you
might even think it's certain so you're
pretty sure that 2+2 is going to
continue to equal for tomorrow you can
say I'm optimistic that 2+2 will
continue to equal 4 so that looks like a
way of thinking about optimism that's
kind of at least a sketch I think of our
common sense notion in the 17th century
after those other old guys we just
looked at
live knits comes along and he is a good
mathematician and he knows a little bit
more about probability theory and he
develops a theory of explicitly of
optimism first one to use the word
interestingly so expectation optimism he
uses that word in French in this 1714
theodicy essay where he talks about the
goodness of God the liberty of
men and the origin of evil so according
to him he's got an independent proof
that God exists from the armchairs on
the a priori proof so you got God God's
the Omni Omni Omni right really good
really powerful really smart so God if
God makes anything is gonna make the
best thing so this must be the best
thing the best possible world of all the
worlds that were available so if there's
something that looks bad to us that had
to be there it couldn't have been better
this is the best possible world sounded
good became a big sort of movement in
Germany the optimism movement until 1755
so the way they were operating was sort
of theoretical optimism we have reasons
and arguments for being optimistic and
we should also think of it as a
practical or lived optimism even in the
face of evil or suffering we should
think you know this really is for the
best and somehow it'll work out even if
we're not exactly clear sometimes how
that's going to go and that sort of ran
into 1755 Lisbon earthquake 9.0 on the
Richter scale and it wasn't just
punishing the bad people it actually
occurred on All Saints Day at 10:00 a.m.
when most of the good people were in
church and the churches were the things
that collapsed and so almost everybody
in church died the few who survived
along with the bad people who weren't in
church come out and try to help the
people who you know are suffering they
run down if you know Lisbon it's sort of
down on a slope towards the port they
run down there and 40 minutes later a
tsunami comes and inundates the rest of
them one-third one to one half of the
population dies immediately eighty-five
percent of the city destroyed
Leibniz says well in another world it
would have been worse
cold comfort right it's really hard to
believe and that was Voltaire's point he
writes Candide about optimism professor
Pangloss and makes optimism look a bit
ridiculous
so then pessimism sort of comes in and
people think we have good reason to be
pessimistic look at the evidence and so
I'm a theoretical pessimist and I will
also just live in a pessimistic way I
will fear I will maybe become apathetic
I will be demoralized in the sense that
I was just discussing I will eat drink
and marry because
eat drink and be merry because tomorrow
we die and then the 19th century is this
kind of great debate between a bunch of
German guys with weird hair Hegel the
great optimist although he doesn't look
like it there
Schopenhauer the great pessimist who
said this is actually the worst of all
possible worlds Karl Marx the optimist
you know it sort of near-term revolution
but ultimately justice and then
Nietzsche definitely a kind of pessimist
though a complicated so we have
theoretical pessimism and what I want to
ask now is do we have to kind of live
the pessimism does that lived pessimism
have to follow from our art the evidence
that things aren't looking so good
whether we're talking about Lisbon and
various earthquakes and so forth or
whether we're talking about the
Anthropocene and our chances of staying
under the two-degree guardrail and I
want to sort of finish the talk by
talking a little bit about what it might
be to live hopefully even in the context
of this rather theoretically pessimistic
situation
inspiration is Immanuel Kant ooze coming
before those 19th century guys and after
the 17th century people that I started
with he was bald but was wearing a wig I
think in this portrait three questions
he think are is central are central to
philosophy what can I know of course
what should I do and then interestingly
what may I hope what is it permitted to
hope and he thinks this actually brings
together the first two questions in an
important way
in the twentieth century this is this
great content Aaron stuff who even in
the midst of World War two he was a
professor in Berlin of all places writes
a three-volume work on the principle of
hope and continues a kind of content
picture he says the work of this emotion
hope requires people who throw
themselves actively into what is
becoming to which they themselves belong
so that's the kind of tenacious picture
of hope even in the face of pessimistic
situation that I want to try to talk a
little bit more about so we talked about
optimism the counterpart notion I think
in hope with respect to hope is this
desire for the thing so you still think
it's good and desirable but instead of
believing that it's probable or
estimating it as probable or certain do
you think that it's merely possible so
this gets us away from the classical
conflation of the two notions you can
hope for something that you don't think
is at all probable I might hope that I'm
going to I don't know upload my mind
onto a computer after the singularity
and live forever but I don't feel
optimistic that that's going to be the
case right so there's a difference
between these concepts hope and optimism
and of course there's a difference with
respect to wish I might wish that the
Warriors had won the finals
that sounds coherent but if I now say I
know the Warriors lost but I really hope
that they want you would think that was
somehow I just didn't get the concept
right so wish is different from hope as
well that can't be the whole story about
hope though so there's this interesting
point that even someone who despairs the
opposite of hope might desire the thing
and believe that it's possible so what
else do we have to add to get genuine
hope I like to take this case from this
movie people in the literature have
brought this up before I did but I like
the case the Shawshank Redemption some
of you will have seen it it's a Stephen
King story turned into a movie we've got
two characters both of them have a life
sentence both of them really want to get
out both of them think it's possible but
one of them succumbs to fear and despair
and the other is sort of motivated by
hope to start digging behind the bed
every night until he finally gets out
through
the sewers and ultimately feels a lot
better than he did when he was inside so
what's the difference it looks like and
this is actually a quotation from the
from the movie it looks like read the
guy who despairs has the same estimation
of the possibility of probability of
what's of what they both want but sort
of articulates it differently so read
says I grant you that it's possible so I
grant you that it's possible but it's so
unlikely the odds are so long it's gonna
be so hard and II says I grant you that
the odds are so long but it's possible
focuses on the possibility so what I
want to suggest is that we call this
focus on the positive possibility that
Hope involves as opposed to despair
actually focusing attending to the fact
that something is possible letting that
motivate a certain kind of maybe effort
to look for pathways or projects start
digging behind the bed getting yourself
involved thinking about that positive
possibility and holding it before
yourself in a way that might motivate
action positive emotion but it's not
irrational it's not just producing
optimism in yourself you still
acknowledge the fact that this is an
extremely unlikely outcome and yet you
remain hopeful so let's suppose that's a
sort of rough-and-ready picture of what
hope is how does it help in the face of
something like the Anthropocene so let's
say we hope for carbon justice right
that was the thing that we said we
wanted to degree guardrail fair
distribution of what remains say we hope
for that that means according to the
what I was just telling you that we
believe it's possible certainly seems
possible we want it we even think we're
morally required to go for it in this
case and we tenaciously focus on that
possibility we consider it we fantasize
about it we imagine what it would be
like to get there we think about how our
hopes would be dashed if we didn't get
there and what the consequences would be
but we keep it rational we don't go into
a kind of optimism that suggests that
our evidence is
different than it is so it's a hopeful
pessimism if you will and how does that
avoid getting into demoralisation in the
way that I suggested sometimes we can in
the face of long odds well I mean if
you're tenaciously focused on the
positive possibility I think it's very
psychologically natural to then start
thinking about as I said before pathways
ways in which you might be involved or
at least someone might be involved in
getting to the ultimate outcome getting
out of the prison for instance so once
you start thinking that way you kind of
build yourself and maybe your community
the people working with you into the
hope so you start hoping not just for
this outcome but for that outcome and
that I contribute to it in some way so I
hope to contribute through all of this
effort to the bringing about this
outcome so with respect to carbon
justice all the little things I try to
do I want them to make a difference
something we hear a lot from a lot of
people certainly my students I want to
me how do I make a difference that seems
really key a kind of consequentialist
picture now I think that when we look
closely at the odds and how much we can
really do as individuals even if we say
yeah I'm hoping to make a difference for
carbon justice we could still face
demoralization we could still face these
long odds and sort of think yeah
actually it's not going to matter much
so here's the final twist I'm talking
about hope for specific outcomes and
just skipped hope as a virtue for the
sake of time I can go back to that if we
want to in the question and answer so
here's the final twist as we know there
are some systems especially in nature
but also in culture and commerce that
are not linear systems this is something
that actually comes up in a lot of the
discussions here I think it belong now
context sometimes it's not just about
aggregates and linear progressions but
rather about feedback loops and sudden
shifts and thresholds and trigger points
and so forth now what is the chance that
you and your the people you convince
around you or the people who are working
around you for carbon justice are going
to be on a tipping point or a threshold
very small right even smaller than the
past
that I was talking the probability of
that one possibility I was talking about
before that you'll make some sort of
difference the thought here is it's
still possible it's still possible that
you'll make this huge difference that
your small actions will come at just the
right moment such that the system trips
in across the tipping point or across
the threshold and you make a big
difference I think if we focus in this
hopeful way on that mere possibility and
it is possible in many cases then it
will be very difficult to feel
demoralized then it will feel be very
difficult to think I'll just sort of let
this one slide I will opportunistically
go ahead and burn this carbon when I
really don't need to let me just finish
by illustrating this with a case and now
we're going to go back to the food
situation which is what the book was in
part about so we know that industrial
animal agriculture is one of the worst
greenhouse gas producers it's worse than
the entire transportation sector
combined we also know it's kind of more
intuitive in this context to see what I
was talking about with thresholds and
nonlinear allottee so there's a kind of
chunkiness about the supply chain in a
huge opaque system like this where it's
not the case that when I stop and get a
chicken sandwich you know which is made
up of maybe one fiftieth of a chicken
depending on what other things they put
in there that somehow one fiftieth of a
chicken dies right so it's not this
direct correlation even if I have 50
sandwiches it might not be the case that
one chicken dies there's you know this
thing going along this system and it
hits thresholds and at some point some
choice does have this big effect a
hundred thousand chickens are ordered
and the farmer produces them and they
become part of the 45 billion chickens
that are processed every year so suppose
I really care about the climate or about
animals or about both and I decided to
give up on animal products facing these
huge numbers makes it hard to be
optimistic makes it hard to think that
you're gonna be making a difference that
demoralization threat comes in and what
I want to suggest
is that we can sort of generate and I
already sort of casually made it but now
I'm going to formally make it a moral
argument what calls a moral argument for
lived hope that would help us avoid
demoralization in this kind of case and
in and throughout the seen cases
generally so you can't get through a
talk by a philosopher without one effort
at a stepwise argument so here's premise
one oppe this is the guy who's thinking
about opportunistically you know he's
demoralized and he's like I'm just gonna
eat that chicken sandwich because it
doesn't make a difference I do care
about the factory farm system I'm
morally opposed to its continuation but
I'm tempted by the thought that if I
make a difference at the miniscule
difference a tempting thought that we
all have early it would be demoralizing
in that way that I was mentioning for
Oppie to have not to have some sort of
hope that his eating choices or the
choices of those he influences have a
significant effect on the factory farm
system so suggesting unless we can focus
on the positive possibility that we make
a significant difference we might face
demoralization demoralization is morally
undesirable especially if the end in
question is something we think is
morally required our duties to future
generations and so forth so given the
facts about the system that is chunky
and not linear and the way I was
suggesting earlier suggests that there's
a moral advantage in having rational
hope that at least one of the food
choices you make throughout your life
maybe you have twenty or thirty thousand
choices left at least one of those
choices is going to be a threshold
choice where you actually get to decide
whether the system shunts forward
whether there was a hundred thousand
chickens get ordered or not the
threshold chicken is yours at that
moment you don't know which and so you
sort of then try to abstain across all
of your choices and have this hope that
one of them makes a huge difference a
hundred thousand chickens or not
depending on how you choose so other
things equal rational hope that at least
one of the food choices he makes or
influences is a threshold choice becomes
morally justified so for moral reasons
we can hope for that it's not it's not
up
it's not the claim that that is going to
happen that would be crazy right think
about the odds but I'm suggesting it's
both morally justified there's a
compelling moral reason to focus on that
mere possibility in the way that hope
does in order to keep us from being
demoralized thank you so Stuart wrote in
1999 a book where he has a chapter on
what he calls tragic optimism so I
thought I would start off our discussion
by just kind of asking you about this so
the quotations up there for them to read
you say Maura my worry actually I want
to look at it on here because there's a
little extra bit my worry is that the
pessimists love being right so much that
they avoid any efforts that might make
them wrong look it all depends on what
time frame you look at everything has
been going to hell as long as anyone can
remember em priors are always dying your
friends are always dying but in the long
sweep of history on average life has
been getting steadily better for as long
as you care to look and then actually
the ellipses what you say next is does
anyone here really want to live in
medieval times have rotten teeth
eat turnips and die at age 27 of
exhaustion
so short-term worst long-term better
maybe the way to resolve it is tragic
optimism I would settle for a world of
tragic optimists so it looks like what
I'm defending is a kind of hopeful
pessimism in the face of what looks like
some not-so-great evidence about the
anthropic Queen and it looks like you're
defending tragic optimism and I wonder
if this is just a difference in
temperament or the way we were raised or
something like that
or whether it's a difference in the
evaluation of the facts involved or
whether it's that we're both pragmatist
of some sort and we think we got to find
a position that will look intellectually
honest but still people keep people
invested in their projects I'm trying to
do something and not being demoralized
and so we just went a different
dressings a same goal
there are certainly optimists and
pessimists and I find that anyone I'm
wrong I'm often wrong because I was
optimist more optimistic than I should
have been are you pessimistic in that
respect just in terms of the judgments
you make in life and you can have
yourselves for all of this at all
say again I'm completely objective at
all the time no you're not
i I actually know a number of facts I
don't have write about the prophecy in
them I think I do this natural thing
where I think I'm an above-average
driver just like 85% of people do it so
I'm optimistic maybe too much about
myself and my abilities but I do yeah I
guess I tend towards maybe because I was
raised in a broadly Calvinist tradition
I feel pessimistic even if I've thrown
off the tradition the pessimism remains
no tradition of pessimism is interesting
concept okay you use moral a lot do you
distinguish moral from ethical just now
I know now that's all same word Wow I
think of it as just Greek and Latin huh
okay great
don't sass me really it is I mean Murali
toss is the translation for ethical mmm
do you buy and you quoted the long-term
sort of optimistic short-term
pessimistic yeah perspective do you yeah
agree with that well what I was
suggesting I mean independent of the way
one of our board members who was a
professional futures Paul Sappho who's
watched himself and other people be
wrong right and wrong and right you know
predicting things and he said in the
near term the optimists are strong and
in the long term the pessimists are
always wrong and it's just something
he's watched and you know he's also the
one who said never make mistake of clear
view for a short distance right right of
something you know was gonna happen but
you know you think it's gonna happen
next week and it's actually next yeah so
I mean I take your point about the
medieval period and you know the
accomplishments that we've achieved
since then I guess I do find so maybe it
is in the end not so much a
temperamental thing but my sense of the
evidence in which case I should defer to
you as someone who knows much more about
the empirical side of this but my sense
of the evidence that I was presenting
from Copenhagen and from some of those
articles suggests that the Anthropocene
is looking pretty precarious for us and
you know there are a lot of pretty
prominent people who are not so
optimistic about our chances as I
mentioned you Jared Diamond yeah it's
true there it is yeah he's an optimist
but he says what I mean by that is that
I think we are 51% likely to survive for
the next hundred years just barely
optimistic and yet even in his book
collapse Jared points out that these
various civilizations have collapsed but
that each one of them did not know about
the others and why they collapsed and
the current global civilization has all
of those stories as part of the
cautionary tales we tell each other
that's right so I guess I'm curious what
your vision is characterized us BNN
an advocate of the soft landing and
throw up a senior the good Anthropocene
so if we combine innovation with
reduction we could make it through you
know that would be a whole discussion
and yeah I'm completely persuaded a good
Anthropocene is well underway and
happening a century the sixth extinction
is not underway and it is probably not
going to happen that's it six these
extinctions are when seventy-five
percent of all species go extinct really
serious stuff has to happen like
asteroid collisions and you know major
volcanic periods and so on none of which
is I mean if the comet hits us I mean
okay
in the entropic seeing we are as gods
and might as well have to get good at it
it used to be that asteroids you know
six to six million years ago can do and
all the dinosaurs didn't do in life that
they did in a lot asteroids are now
easily detectable and relatively easily
diverged we've been two or three talks
by setting out to do that one of the
best early climate scientists William
Ruddiman has basically pointed out we've
probably seen our last glacial maximum
the ice ages where the ice comes down
which is the big event yeah and there
was a while when Stephen Schneider and
others in the 70s thought that might be
coming he then reversed it when he
looked deeper into the data and it's now
the case that probably that will never
occur again as long as humans would
rather it didn't you know it happened
inadvertently because of rice farming
and various things that we've done
through time that put up more of these
greenhouse gases that prevented what
should have been the interglacial that
isn't supposed to have ended by now
right it's not so the basic frame is you
know I think just factually yeah not
that what one does to that is I think
bear down not so much on the attitude as
on the details of the situation and so
if you can buy some time with putting
some sulfur dioxide in the stratosphere
while we're cleaning up the atmosphere
we're you know X hundred thousand people
a year die of the particles coming out
of these coal-fired plants when we fix
that more sunlight is getting in and so
it's getting hotter so you can offset
that with one thirtieth the amount of
stuff in the stratosphere that'd be
great
I think David Keith climatologist makes
a very good case that air capture of
carbon dioxide is hard but plausible and
he's working on that many people are
working on it I think in the scope of
the century that probably will come to
pass in conservation I see things more
things getting better than getting worse
especially in the context to last you
hundred years yet so I'm sorry to get
into all of that but I think the details
really count here's a symmetry question
I have for you know we can start to yeah
ask around it's pretty clear that in
your when you're in a terrible situation
hope is a really good thing to have
right is it the case that when you're in
a good situation despair is a good thing
to have many do it and they become
weirdly self-destructive and other
people destructive and so on but it
can't be a good thing to have that seems
right I mean if despair is just
believing something is possible but and
desiring it but somehow not focusing on
the possibility and instead just kind of
giving up on it thinking that the long
odds make it very up make it such that
we shouldn't waste time on it then that
does seem irrational to me I mean one
question might be if we're optimistic
about something are we also hoping for
it and actually I think of hope as a
just a broader character category than
optimism so we might be we might think
it's you know likely the case that it's
gonna be sunny tomorrow but we might
also still hope for it so I think in if
optimism is right about the human future
there's also a place for hope there but
I agree that a lot of this comes down to
empirical details you
rightly infer induce from the pass the
long past some some things about the
future I guess my sense as a total non
expert is that the way that scientific
papers that I look at casually talk at
least sometimes is as though this is
some very unusual rupture that this is
not you know past behavior cannot
predict our way out of this one and I'm
not saying it's not possible I mean part
of the picture was that it's possible we
should focus on that but that it's not
clear that we can say that it's likely
there's your project of hope and
optimism is one of the very few such
things I know that it's attractive this
significant amount of money compared to
the things that focus on the terrible
threats that we face and how are we
going to head them off and how can i
frame this thing I love working on
anyway in this somehow a climate change
in the mode yeah there's a lot of that
going on I think that's so you know
optimism pessimism are sort of
operational modes as near as I can tell
so Andy Grove writes a wonderful book
called only the paranoid survive talking
about running a business yeah and boy is
there a lot to that my wife who's a
serial entrepreneurs in that category
she's always focused on what she knows
could very very likely go wrong and
heading it off before it does that and
yet she has the optimism just our
business after business not all of them
which succeeded and didn't slow her down
a bit so there's some kind of I think
maybe we are getting the pragmatism now
balancing of using these both of these
things in a way that keeps things
exploring and moving forward I'm curious
just one last question if you would be
open to so I was trying to avoid what I
was calling irrationality so I wanted to
focus on hope and think that that's
rational even if it's merely possible
what we're talking about do you think
there as a pragmatist there are some
cases in which the end is so important
that even if you thought it wasn't
likely even if you thought it wasn't
probable you should still say you're
optimistic about it Act opt
basically about it try to make yourself
believe in the sort of irrational way
this is the kind of Pascal II and you
know leap of faith picture yeah I mean
okay if you only play the game when the
odds are all in your favour it's not
going to be that interesting a game and
if you have to assume that you always
only win and the things you care about
always only win oh you know the Warriors
have hit it why would I pay any more
attention oh but I'm not saying should
we act I agree that we should act in
such cases but should we try to become
optimists should we sort of believe even
in the face of evidence that we're not
in a pretty good situation a optimist
hopefully does not do that in the face
of evidence a hopeful person does that
yeah okay that's right
and and I think a hope hope is more like
an emotion and optimism is more like it
you pointed it in terms of probability
yeah that's probably right yeah probably
right should we do questions and just
the way the way that we are gonna do
questions is that we're gonna move the
mic around so raise your hand and the
mic will move to you and then while the
other person is asking the question the
answer is being answered and so these
guys aren't going to call on you but one
of us will hand you that mic if you're
gonna get your hand up and look at them
hold your hand up and look at them and
I'll take the first question to take the
time while we figure out the next mic
move the I think it's really worth
teasing out this hope optimism change I
think you know a it's could it be that
there's a that there's a good human idea
in that if you are not optimistic about
the future that you will act to
counteract it so if you're worried about
this dangerous future which you know
every science-fiction movie portrays for
us will you hope for a better future for
your children and act on things in a
kind of a selfish ratcheting way that as
long as everyone's doing that ratcheting
effect counteracts it and if we if we
didn't think that the future was going
to be dystopic would we just become
complacent so is it a good immune
response for Humanity is what I'm asking
as any dystopian story been as loved as
Star Trek I'm just wondering Blade
Runner absolutely yeah
but in terms of an ongoing thing they
got season after season like it's Game
of Thrones say some but they quality in
Game of Thrones gets away with it
because it's sort of saying well
remember all those fond fantasies we
used to have about knights and kings and
stuff well I are really awful sorted our
point about you know everybody is cruel
and this is a Steven Pinker story Game
of Thrones I'm sorry Mad Max and that
madman had men Mad Men strikes me I mean
it was fabulous
sequence of shows but it struck me as a
version of the present being very smug
about the past remember when we used to
treat women that awful you know at least
it's a little less awful now never when
we used to just have a picnic and leave
all the trash out well isn't that long
ago I remember that period
there's this another difference between
us hallelujah late thirties there you go
late seventies right I'm a question here
I had a I had a question if if ignorance
is bliss
would you consider information to be a
burden and the environment in which
people are being hopeful is an
environment that they can affect as as
individuals
so is uninformed hopefulness more
positive than informed hopefulness no no
where was that said well no I don't know
where that was said it just seems to be
it's not a it's not a truth it's just
something I grew up with it that
ignorant that the ignorant are blissful
and that the meek shall inherit the
earth the kind of things that ignorant
is bliss and that and we're talking
about the dogs I know they were gonna
die okay I think I think it's probably
ignorant of death is talked about I just
feel like we lived in we live in the
information age the the over informed
and that often inform and that we we
often burden ourselves with so much
information that we hinder ourselves and
being able to affect the environment
with as much effect as an individual
that's better informed to what they can
do and actually affect can can actually
hope to do so for what may I hope an
outside point of view you might think
it'd be better for a bunch of those
people not to know the facts about the
Anthropocene at least the ones I was
citing insofar as that might demoralize
them and the way I was suggesting from
the inside especially about good
Enlightenment sort of person you might
think you know no we should go for
knowledge we should understand the
theoretical situation and then make
rational choice about the lived response
to it so I think there might be an
inside-outside difference there I think
don't settle for the first story you
hear the only time I've done something
political was when I put on a public
event to dramatize overpopulation in
1969 a bunch of a starved in public and
there's a tough educational week and it
was based on my old teacher Paul they're
like saying that we're seriously [ __ ]
in terms of human population is the
j-curve just going to go up and up up
until you know it's all hopeless that
very time when his book came out was
exactly when the population curve
inflected from a j2 and s and it's a
total waste of my starvation in the hog
farm and everybody else's suffering all
that week it was just and I should have
known because Paul is a biologist
population biologist of Checkerspot
butterflies and the demographers the
human demographers knew all along that
there's this thing called the
demographic transition that people start
to do a little better and they
immediately have fewer children they
moved to town they immediately after
your children education gets around more
medical stuff gets around more women
immediately take the opportunity to
control how many children they have and
when they're not out in the country
trying to make a subsistence farm work
with their seven kids they're in town
trying to educate their one-and-a-half
kids and that turned out to be the truth
and you know I bought the first kind of
romantic story that I heard from Paul
and later regretted it and I've
hopefully not made that mistake since
it's very easy to buy these these
overdramatize tough stories so let me
say it's something on the other side of
that which is that look you know yeah
it's true that the story can change and
we might be pessimistic and then learn
some things and start becoming but what
would be the loss if we had been hopeful
pessimists all the way a lot so what I'm
suggesting with this active tenacious
hope
focuses on the possibility and still
acts if it turns out that we were wrong
and we should have been optimist all
along nothing's been lost right but if
we start off with the optimism and we
only act optimistically because we think
we have theoretical reasons that think
things are gonna get better then there's
the real risk of disappointment and
enervation that comes if the backs
turned out to go the other way you do
want your harsh prophecies to be
self-defeating prophecies and to some
extent that was the case and so lady
lady room is a girlfriend of mine
Stephanie Mills when she graduated from
Mills College said I'm really sorry but
I cannot have any children and women in
my generation that think very seriously
of adding this whole human overburden of
Earth and handsome bright ladies ooh
that word went out and she was hither
and yon telling that story and a lot of
people took it seriously as a result in
the 70s a lot of my hippie cohorts were
very cruel to their children and cruel
to couples they knew that had children
but you know no great harm was done and
you know the idea that we should
probably think about in this aggregate
term how many people is right for a
given society or a given planet was
right and so in that sense I think the
you know the the pessimism that Paul and
Stephanie put out there was a helpful
thing yeah so I have a proposition or a
provocation that I think flips our
analysis on its head and possibly leads
us to different conclusions entirely and
that is the way you've talked about
deconstructing hope and optimism is to
place them before action and say the
hope and optimism or demoralization
modulate the possibility of action if
you flip it on its head what if action
is the important thing
action is a thing that generates emotion
it's a completely different theory of
human nature from the Western tradition
and that the action produces the hope
and if the action produces the hook then
the most important thing to think about
is how do we create agency
you talk about your wife and serial
entrepreneur having both pessimism and
optimism paranoia and hope at the same
time but where would she be if she did
not actually have the agency to start a
new business if she did not have the
ability and ate therefore which is where
the end result leads us in a very
different place is that this becomes not
an account of the individual
psychological orientation towards acting
in this kind of a space but all of these
social institutions and the systems we
put in place that enable action even for
those people who don't start from a
place of hope or act or optimism I like
that you know what I mean
so that last part was key I think
because initially I was gonna say look I
don't know what it would mean to say
that you should think about acting first
before you have any sense of what the
likelihood is of the outcome or what
outcome you're going for whether you
should be hopeful or pessimistic what
you're suggesting is that agency is as
much a product of what you've been
brought up in and where you are as
you're sort of thinking and reflecting
about the probabilities or the
possibility in question I think that's
right I guess I would maybe there's a
kind of there's got to be a place and
it's certainly in the Eastern tradition
as well as the Western tradition there
is a place for adult pausing reflecting
on what you're doing and why you're
doing it ethical deliberation right and
it looks as though there at least in in
that moment and I agree it is an
individual moment but it still happens
we think about whether we'll make a
difference whether it's likely the
outcome that we're going for whether we
should still be hopeful despite its in
probability so I would want to talk more
a little bit more about context in which
that looks really rarified but I would
want to at least support the idea that
sometimes in some cases rational adults
need to do that
no no I was trying to avoid faith I
think that hope is rational because it
just thinks of in terms of possibilities
but it can still be motivating if we do
it in the way I was suggesting faith
looks like in the face of theoretical
pessimism you still leap up and say yeah
we're gonna make it or it's going to
happen and I think of that as irrational
yeah this is informed hope though so
yeah another question back here well
it's all to sort of piggyback on that I
think one thing that's evident in the
conversation around climate change is
the tent there's a tension between this
rational assessment of the situation
versus our pessimism and hope and
there's such a avoidance of pessimism
I mean avoidance of despair because we
want to have hope but then your
definition of hope was about you know
having a reasonable expectation you're
gonna have a significant impact but then
we keep asking people to be hopeful that
a rational assessment will say well it's
not gonna actually be a significant
impact you know so we could be like I'm
pessimistic in the sense that the I
don't see the ice cap not melting yeah
but you know I can be optimistic that
something else will come along but not
optimistic that my choice to drive here
or not is going to have a significant
impact on that okay so so I mean it but
the nuance around how it relates to the
individual this more nuanced hope is a
really really important conversation so
you know but yeah how much do we need to
make sure we don't slip into this
uninformed irrational not assessing the
part not assigning a little
probabilities to our to where we place
our hope okay so they answer the SHA
second damp so don't answer that system
is not gonna work I'll find a different
way of getting at it you know so I think
it's key to recognize that I never said
that anything you take on in terms of
hope changes your assessment of the
probabilities it's merely possible in
fact it's incredibly unlikely that
you're gonna make some significant
hold change right but the thought is
it's at least possible and instead of
irrationally leaping into faith that you
are gonna make some sort of big
significant change if you do this hope
thing which is voluntary you can focus
in the way I would suggest is on that
thing and image it and fantasize that
will totally concur for like riding your
bike but for having a significant impact
on the whole thing like then it's don't
keep thinking riding your bike is where
the hope is how much do we remember to
look like raised a bar and what we're
looking for
not this choice I mean that would be you
should maximize the pot the
probabilities right so let's say all of
your choices and the people who you can
influence let's say you know this kind
of hope might be that one of those
choices makes it perfect indifference
and that might still be enough to
motivate thank you I like the idea of
action being a determinant here cuz I
was around and was in the thick of the
communes that were starting up in the
60s and 70s and these were based sort of
on a despair about civilization I was
born in one of those oh my god hear what
I have to say and say where you played
in that so a lot of us people who gave
up in civilization and went off mostly
to rural situations to basically
reinvent civilization and we were taking
action and showing that free love would
work they are distributing and money
would work that you could build Jesusa
films and they wouldn't leak and anybody
could garden and universal failure lots
learned and one of the things we learned
is that civilization wasn't so bad even
compared to our alternative we all came
back to town and started businesses by
and large
so did my parents and one other school
board and you know it did effective
things because why not did something and
it failed in interesting ways and then
profoundly engaging ways and you know
it's like being in the Peace Corps if
you've been in a commune or in a kibbutz
or whatever you've really been through
something and learned a lot of lessons
you apply to the rest of your life the
people who've had that kind of idealism
of despair about civilization who did
not act on it became really boring
cynics and so I think you know that
there's having the personal engagement
of just screwed let's do it
the world will sort you out yeah and and
now I start you out but it'll it will
give you stuff that no matter what it is
you attempted will be useful in what it
is you try the next few times yeah I
think the temporal perspective here is
is crucial yeah and and it harkens on to
the big concern that I have that people
who are hopeful and are trying to be
change agents all of a sudden realize
that their efforts are thwarted and
therefore they become despairing well
what is the worldview that that would
lead to that I think it's a worldview of
a lack of a temporal perspective because
you know when you think about the
long-term issues it's kind of like
things work for a period of time and
then they don't work and indeed life is
a rollercoaster right so sometimes
things are up and sometimes you go back
down and but as soon as you're down you
realize that you're gonna go back up
again and so I think that the concept of
hope has to be considered within the
context of a worldview in a worldview
which would suggest that hey I've been
hopeful I've tried to effect change I've
failed and therefore I'm going to be
despairing that's not the right hook
that's not the right worldview I don't
turn ative which is consistent with
Buddhist philosophy yin and yang things
go well for what a period of time and
then they don't go very well or
consistent with Christian theology you
know when one door closes another one
opens
I mean I think that's what life is all
about and that's what hope is all about
so you're hopeful that something is
going to happen at a particular point in
time you get shut down completely but do
you go to despair no I think you go to
acceptance that this is the way life is
I'm not going to I'm not gonna you know
completely abandon what I'm hope what
I'm hoping for but I understand as you
say the Thresh you know the threshold
point or I would say just the the yin
and yang of life is such that okay I've
been shut down this time so now I'm just
going to keep going and maybe next year
or maybe two years down the line things
are going to be different I'm going to
be more successful so I would like both
of you to talk about the what I think is
the crucial issue here which is the
temporality of Hope and and also what
the world view is that leads people to
despair and not being hopeful
I mean I think what you were describing
is something close to my position a
hopeful pessimism like it does look as
though many doors are gonna close but
you keep focusing on at least the
possibility that some good will some big
good will result from at least one of
your actions over a long period of time
and fixate on that tenaciously and let
that motivate you psychologically to
keep on keeping on so in a way it's very
consonant with the picture I do think
that the thing about I mean the Eastern
tradition is complicated and rich but
the Buddhist tradition in my view anyway
goes a little closer to the Stoics and
the Greek tradition in that they suggest
that we shouldn't hope and shouldn't be
optimistic right but rather only go for
the things that you can control the
Greek term Otto Axia
tranquility stoic say all you can do is
control your character your responses
your intentions that's all you should
look to don't hope because that will
lead to fear disappointment that I think
isn't consonant with the picture that I
was portrayed yeah you know the one
thing the Greek I guess anyway the
ancient philosopher the Peale's means
Lucretius yeah so here's a hard over
apparently pessimist in a way an
empiricist in a way and don't believe
these silly stories about after lives
and gods and all that junk maybe a
pretty chipper guy I mean you know you
lived near the edge in town and was in a
way more persuasive because of that he
was I would see him as a tragic optimist
actually and one worth paying attention
to and you know sort of on the side he
invented to Tom Orton and spread the
atomic theory rather early in history
you never know who's gonna be right
stuff like that so Andrews gonna stick
around so there are no there are more
questions and they'll be more time for
Andrew to sign his books as well we've
got
something for you oh there's one more
thing I wanted so and one more thing I
needed yeah the grant that I'm part of
we had a big conference a couple weeks
ago and we got some swag and I had an
extra piece of sway and I thought in
gratitude to Stuart for coming out and
doing this and talking with me and
moderating and I have for you our very
own challenge coin which you will see in
Latin on the back carpet art millennium
which is the domain where optimism wins
thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]